eine Stadt die vor großen Umbrüchen
steht
das Embargo ist
unser Untergang wenn der Staat damit
viel Geld einspringt kann er doch eine
große Chance sein
die Industriestadt Schwedt wuchs in der
DDR rund um die Raffinerie die Öl aus
Russland verarbeitet doch damit ist ab
Januar Schluss die Bundesregierung kappt
die Abhängigkeit von russischen Öl und
verspricht der Stadt Millionen für einen
Umbau doch die Sorgen in der Region sind
groß
hier in der Eisarena trainieren Kinder
aus der Stadt und Umgebung sogar aus dem
nahen Polen kommen Sie um Eishockey zu
spielen Trainer Bert Köhler gibt der
Jugend in der Grenzregion damit eine
Perspektive
wir sind in Brandenburg geisteshalle ja
gibt viel zu wenig Möglichkeiten ja viel
zu wenig
neuen Vereine sind auf die Halle
angewiesen Michael Schacher und Hartmut
puckelwald bauten die Sportarena in
Eigenregie die beiden Eishockey-Fans
haben seit 2009 viel Kraft und jede
Menge Ideen in dieses Projekt gesteckt
doch die gestiegenen Energiekosten
machen sie ratlos
die Leute müssen unter hierher kommen
meine verwundert Kilometer haben auch da
schon die teuren Spritpreise jetzt hier
und und die haben nicht mehr Geld wir
haben die haben ja Beiträge die Sie im
Verein zahlen und von den Beitrag muss
das alles dort
finanziert werden und das geht nicht
ein Freizeitangebot für die Jugend die
beiden haben dafür alles gegeben eine
kleine Fläche eine effiziente Kühlung
schon immer wussten Michael schacherei
und Hartmut puckelwald es muss sich auch
rentieren
und wo geht es nicht mehr und dem Punkt
aber langsam erreicht ganz ganz
begeistert
die Eisarena ist eine der wenigen
verbliebenen Sportstätten hier in
Schwedt seit der Wände hat sich die
Einwohnerzahl in der Stadt an der Oder
halbiert in Energiekrise Inflation das
ist für viele hier ein Schock jetzt
kommt auch noch Angst um Arbeitsplätze
in der Raffinerie hinzu
das Embargo ist unser Untergang kann man
nicht verstehen wir wollen russisches Öl
wir wollen die Brust weil wir wollen
dass Sie alles ankommen dass alles so
ist wie früher ne wir haben da überhaupt
gar nichts mit den Russen oder wie auch
immer es hat alles gut funktioniert und
wir können das nicht verstehen ne ist
das so
vor drei Jahren vor der Krise sind
Henrike freye und Dirk Hagendorf nach
Schwedt gezogen der junge Vater arbeitet
zwar in einer Firma auf dem
raffineriegelände die hat sich aber
schon länger grüner Energie zugewandt
für die Zukunft ganz gut gerüstet meiner
Meinung nach ja deshalb ist spät die die
erste Wahl derzeit
auch in der PCK Raffinerie weiß man
fossile Brennstoffe haben auf Dauer
keine Zukunft eine erste Anlage zur
Herstellung von Wasserstoff ist geplant
doch der sogenannte
Transformationsprozess braucht Jahre und
die Raffinerie wenigstens für eine
Übergangszeit noch Öl
Dominique Eser der seit erstem November
hier als Ingenieur angestellt ist hofft
dass sein Arbeitgeber schnell genügend
Ersatz für russisches Öl findet
jetzt läuft alles im Hintergrund also
Gespräche mit mit Polen laufen ja die
die Rostock Pipeline wird
verbessert oder ausgebaut diese ganzen
Projekte laufen ja jetzt an Kriegen auch
Unterstützung vom Bund und alles
deswegen also es läuft schon irgendwie
man hat das Gefühl ja es geht weiter
oft trifft sich Dominik ESA mit Freunden
zu Hause aus Mangel an Alternativen
erzählen sie für 20 bis 30 jährige hat
die Stadt wenig zu bieten dabei sind
alle von ihnen hochqualifizierte
Fachkräfte die doch dringend in Schwedt
gehalten werden sollen
die
Älteren sind viele und bestimmen was
hier passiert und für Rentner ist das ja
hier eigentlich der Traum schlechthin
die haben Angebote ohne Ende und weil
wir einfach so wenige sind gibt es auch
wenig Angebote weil man hat ja auch
weniger Abnehmer ich verstehe das schon
dadurch brechen einmal aber immer mehr
weg und dann gehen halt immer immer mehr
und ja woanders hin und kommen halt auch
nicht unbedingt wieder
sie wollen erstmal hier bleiben sehen
trotz der schwierigen Zeiten für den
Industriestandort Schwedt eine Zukunft
die Sorgen sind definitiv berechtigt
aber ich habe jetzt persönlich noch
keinen Menschen kennengelernt oder von
jemanden erfahren der aufgrund dessen
der Situation überhaupt seinen Job
verloren hat also da werden erstmal nur
Ängste gemacht und die Ängste die sind
in den Köpfen aber es kommt auch mal
drauf an wie man fragt also da sind sehr
viele auch diese positiv gestimmt aber
diese Stimmen hört man öfter nicht weil
die die halt die Angst machen
reibedienung oft laut also
Dominik ESA sieht das von der Politik
beschlossene Öl embargo auch als Chance
gerade jetzt guckt man ja auch nach
erneuerbaren Energie elektrolyseanlagen
wasserstoffanlagen allem drum und dran
also je früher desto besser ne aber
vielleicht hat es nicht so
scharf kommen sollen also er sanfte
ausklingen lassen das mal gucken
die Raffinerie hat auch nach der Wende
vielen hier Wohlstand gebracht in dieser
Eigenheimsiedlung wohnen gut bezahlte
Industriearbeiter mit ihren Familien
mittendrin betreiben Liana Zaug und ihre
Tochter Nicki einen Kosmetiksalon auch
sie spüren nun die Unsicherheit bei der
Kundschaft
Kunden melden sich auch hier bei uns ab
sie warten wirklich ab wenn man dort
eine monatlichen Abschlag von 700 Euro
für Gast bekommt also dann ist natürlich
nichts für die Kosmetik übrig das kann
ich aber auch verstehen
Niki zaux Mann arbeitet in der
Raffinerie wie so viele in dieser
Wohngegend neu bauen oder investieren
kann jetzt hier aber niemand man sieht
es an den Häusern sie werden nicht mehr
verkauft weil viele kein Kredit bekommen
obwohl sie im PC arbeiten war alles
schwammig ist also oder die Leute sind
verunsichert auch wenn beide im PCK
arbeiten
was ist wenn bei dir einen Job verlieren
man muss gucken
dieses Gebiet am Stadtrand wollte die
städtische Wohnungsbaugenossenschaft
attraktiver machen um junge Menschen
anzuziehen diese Reihenhäuser oder so
das war mal so ein Wunsch in Richtung
Fachkräfte Sicherung auch der Raffinerie
gibt genügend die jetzt quasi kein
Eigentum haben wollen aber gerne mal so
eine Art Haus Reihenhaus wohnen möchten
Einkommen danach haben deswegen hatten
wir das mal so jetzt mit eingeplant doch
die Hoffnung auf Zuzug ist jetzt
gedämpft die Bauarbeiten liegen auf Eis
die Krise Raffinerie bleibt zu bestehen
kriegen wir weiter Öl in Schwedt oder
nicht oder schrumpft die Stadt jetzt
doch schneller weiter hat uns dazu
gezwungen meinen kleinen Stopp
zwischendurch einzulegen
eine Pause die sich Astrid Brendel nicht
leisten kann hier in ihrem Blumenladen
laufen Vorbereitungen für die
Weihnachtszeit die Inhaberin hofft
endlich wieder auf mehr Umsatz
die Umsätze sind ungefähr seit Juni so
um 5% gesunken
aber eben
höhere Lohnnebenkosten und alles so
höhere Kosten dadurch denke ich mal wird
das Polster was man sich eigentlich nach
der corinna-krise wieder langsam
aufbauen konnte wird dann wahrscheinlich
dahin schmelzen seit Oktober muss Astrid
brennel ihren zwölf Mitarbeiterinnen
mehr Mindestlohn zahlen auch das kommt
zur falschen Zeit man versucht
eigentlich positiv und optimistisch zu
sein so ist mein Charakter aber man ist
trotzdem sehr unsicher
ob Kosmetikerin junge Fachkräfte oder
Unternehmer sie alle sind besorgt
dennoch hoffen sie dass der Umbruch eine
Chance mit sich bringt und Schwedt auch
ohne russisches Öl eine gute Zukunft hat